Now that I am getting closer to the end of watching these Disney follow-up films, I can honestly say that
the most amusing of all is "Cinderella 3".
Yes. You are kidding me? The third "Cinderella" movie? That is ridiculous!
Look at this opening! It doesn't even look like it's going to be something!
It looks like a sequel that is even worse than the previous one!
But, when I told others that I was going to watch all these Disney follow-up films, I heard again and again
that "Cinderella 3" is good. "Wait until you get to" Cinderella 3 ". That's a good one."
And, for the most part, they are pretty much right.
Are there any problems? Yes, I think that can be expected from every Disney follow-up film.
Is it my favorite? No, but, again, it's - How should I say it? - simply the most enjoyable.
Like I said before, it starts a bit floury and cheap with a silly song. Not very impressive.
But, suddenly, the bad guys return: the stepmother and the stepisters.
They find the magic wand of the magic fairy, turn it into stone,
and travel back in time to ensure that the step sister is the one with whom the shoe fits.
Thus, everything has changed: Cinderella is left behind and she has lost her 'end well, all right'.
The bad guys are taken to the palace,
they hypnotize the prince making him think that the sister is the one he has fallen in love with,
and now Cinderella must penetrate the palace and convince him of what is really going on
without being caught by the guards or the bad stepmother.
On the one hand, this sounds incredibly forced and foolish, and ... yes, I think that's a bit too,
but, for such a forced and foolish idea, they do everything they can do with it.
They have realized that the bad guys are the most interesting characters, and a lot of time is spent on them.
Look at the drawings of them. Look at these close-ups.
They are just so slinky, and they love being on the screen every second, and we do!
I remember that there is a scene where Cinderella sneaks in like a servant, and covers her face,
and the stepmother looks at the reflection in the water in a certain way, and she can see her face,
and I really had something like, "Oh, no" Which is amazing!
I sincerely said "oh, no" during an "Cinderella" movie, let alone during a follow-up movie. That's insane!
But, moreover, they actually have a lot of characters who had little development
given much more development in previous films.
The king, for example, is much more than just a man bouncing up and down
while shouting "Ah! give me grandchildren!"
They made him a very sensitive man who lost his wife years ago,
and therefore gives a jewel to his future daughter-in-law, and it is actually very sweet.
One of the step sisters is also much more developed. And what makes this so incredibly smart
is the fact that this connects to the second film, "Cinderella 2".
Yes!! That stupid sequel that nobody cares about. They really have a few things that tie in with that.
Not only have they given her character more depth and a storyline, but there are even characters
from the second film that are also introduced in this film.
Do you remember the woman who was at the head of the servants?
Of course you don't know that anymore! Because nobody remembers the second film!
But she's in here. What an incredible attention to details!
Even the prince, who perhaps had one line of text in the first film and, I don't know,
maybe two in the second - he was clearly nothing more than a feast for the eyes -
has much more personality in this film.
Well. Not very much anymore, but there is, no doubt, a personality.
He is gentle, sympathetic and charming, but you get to know him a little better.
Enough to make sure you want to see him with the right person.
The animation is fantastic
and what's great about it is that it doesn't necessarily try to recreate the same animation as in the first movie.
"Bambi 2" fell a bit into that trap, and while it wasn't bad at all or something like that,
you are constantly reminded that it is not entirely unique.
This, although it is a follow-up film, feels like something unique.
The world of imagination becomes a lot more threatening and creative.
There is a scene where stepmother Cinderella imprisons in a giant pumpkin, and it's all dirty and nasty inside,
and these strands seize the horse and wrap itself around him
and then she turns the cat into an evil coachman who laughs madly as he starts to swing the pumpkin off a cliff,
and it's just crazy! It is something you want to see in a sequel to a fairy tale.
It gets a bit darker, it gets a little bit disturbed and it gets a lot more fun.
It is as if it is half Cinderella and half Tim Burton. It's just wonderful to watch.
So. Okay, this movie sounds great. Is it that too?
Well ... There are a few minor issues that prevent it from becoming a complete whole,
and I don't think it's just mosquito sifting.
The largest is Cinderella itself.
Which does not mean that the character is poorly executed, I mean that they have animated her very well,
and the pace is right, and there is even a scene when she finds out that everything has changed,
in which you don't even see her reaction.
You only see that she puts her hand on the door, and that's basically all you need.
Small moments like this are really, really good.
But the problem is in the story. It's a bit like in "The Little Mermaid": She doesn't learn anything.
It is not undergoing development. She just wants to achieve something, and she achieves it.
I think it's just a distracting contrast
when you see what all the other characters are experiencing and all the changes they are facing.
In addition, the moral is sometimes a bit weird, such as the continuous idea
that when you touch someone's hand you immediately know if you are in love, and ... yes, I know
Dinsey. Fairytales. They teach you even stranger lessons than this when you really think about it, but ...
I do not know. This seems particularly strange.
For a film that tries very hard to solve the dated problems of the first film,
it seems that this is something that is clearly very distracting where they might be
should have thought again.
In addition, this film has three climaxes.
Yes, there is one in which the prince rescues her, then there is one in which she rescues herself,
and then there is one in which she saves him, and it just goes everywhere.
But they are all very nice.
There are all green things flying in all directions, and a choir goes from 'ohohoh'.
It is something that you can clearly see that the animators, and the writers, and the directors have enjoyed working,
and we can feel their pleasure.
The hard work and effort is clearly present in a project that there should not have been anything.
They have given 110% to something that was simply meant to be put on the market quickly,
but they really did their best, and you can see they really did their best.
But, yes, those problems that I mentioned earlier are still valid problems.
They focus a bit too much on the secondary characters, and yes, I know, from the first film
you could say that too, but the center was still her need, her wish,
that she had to endure everything in order to get what she needed, worked hard and eventually received her reward.
Here I think it's a bit of the same thing, work hard and get a reward,
but we have already seen that, so why is that still interesting?
But, in my opinion, the rest is so amusing and so insane, and so enjoyable
that I see it a bit, and I think a lot of other people do that too.
The only thing I can say about it is that what everyone says about it is strange enough.
It is very entertaining, and I heartily recommend it.
I can't say it's perfect. I can't say it's a Disney classic or something like that, but it's just a huge amount of surreal joy.
I love how they took something that was pretty useless and even a bit of a stupid idea
and have turned it into something that was just cool,
and focused on the elements that were most enjoyable from the first film.
If you want a Disney follow-up movie that shouldn't have existed, but is still very, very well cared for,
then "Cinderella 3" is, bizarre enough, the film to watch.